y no nos olvidamos del día internacional
de la mujer juana en el marco de esta
fecha hablo alexia putellas la jugadora
del barcelona y vigente balón de oro y
premio the best que la certifican como
la mejor futbolista del momento qué
opina ella del día internacional de los
derechos de la mujer
para reinvindicar
creo que hemos conseguido mucho
lógicamente pero creo que aún queda
mucho por hacer
y al final desde nuestro papel vamos a
intentar hacer todo lo posible para que
llegue un día que no sea un día para
reivindicar sino que sea un mero día que
quede en la historia de antes de este
día se utilizaba para reivindicar
derechos
erradicar situaciones desfavorables de
la mujer
díaz para reivindicar y no felicitar